hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live die Weihnachtsgottesdienste
im Kölner Dom sie liefen in diesem Jahr
etwas anders ab als sonst der Grund
Warnungen vor islamistischen
Terrorangriffen noch vor Heiligabend
wurde der Kölner Dom für die
Öffentlichkeit verschlossen und von
bombenspürhunden durchsucht dennoch
fanden die Weihnachtsgottesdienste wie
geplant statt wenn auch mit verstärkten
Polizeikontrollen dafür aber ohne
weitere Zwischenfälle und vor allem
friedlich wir sehen hier gerade die
Bilder von den vergangenen Feiertagen
und die Besucherschlangen die alle
kontrolliert wurden vor Ort parallel
dazu durchsuchte die Polizei in Wesel
eine Wohnung fünf Personen wurden dabei
festgenommen es soll sich bei den
Männern um tatschiken handeln die dem
islamistischen Staat der Provinz
corassan angehören einem Ableger der is
mittlerweile sind laut Berichten vier
der Männer wieder auf freiem Fuß der
fünfte ein 30-jähriger tike sei
weiterhin in Gewahrsam zur
Gefahrenabwehr über die Geschehnisse in
Köln die Bedeutung und auch die
anhaltende Bedrohung die drohende Gefahr
denn es gilt noch immer die höchste
sicherheitswahnstufe um den Kölner Dom
darüber wollen wir heute bei uns hier
bei ZDF heute live reden gleich mit dem
Kölner Polizeisprecher Wolfgang Baldes
und mit meinem heutigen Studiogast
Professor Dr Susanne Schröter
Professorin am Institut für ologie an
der Goethe Universität Frankfurt am Main
und gerne wie immer gesehen eure Fragen
Anregungen und Kommentare dazu die ihr
uns gerne über die Kommentarspalten
stellen könnt oder auch gerne via Mail
ja wer steckt hinter dem islamistischen
Staat in der Provinz corasan und wie
gefährlich ist er dazu begrüße ich jetzt
Susanne Schröter sie ist etthnologin an
der und Hochschullehrerin an der Gothe
Uni Frankfurt und sie forscht seit
Jahren schon zu den Themen Islamismus
und jihadismus Frau Schröter danke dass
sie sich heute Abend für uns Zeit
genommen haben schönen guten Abend ich
grüße sie guten Abend sehr gerne ganz
kurz mal zu den Fakten was man bisher
weiß
2015 hat sich dieser Ableger gegründet
und seit 2019
reicht der Arm bis nach Deutschland bei
uns es wurden Anschläge schon in
Deutschland geplant es gab 2021 erste
Festnahmen und diese jüngsten Ereignisse
um den Kölner Dom zeigen ja dass dieses
Netzwerk scheinbar vor Ort rings um
Düsseldorf noch ganz aktiv ist trotz
festen gut funktioniert wie ernsthaft
schätzen Sie die Gefahr denn noch ein
oder wie gut ist dieses Netzwerk immer
noch also ich würde gerne ein bisschen
vor der Gruppe anfangen damit unsere
Zuschauer auch vielleicht einordnen
können was ist das eigentlich für eine
Gruppe welche Gruppen muslimischen
Gruppen sind eigentlich Jihadisten das
heißt versuchen eine bestimmte Mission
mit Gewalt durchzusetzen und dazu muss
man wissen der Islam ist ja eine riesige
Weltreligion mit sehr unterschiedlichen
Spielarten und einige äh Muslime die
nennen wir Islamisten oder Vertreter
eines politischen Islam
ähm die sind der Meinung dass ä die
gesamte Gesellschaft nach islamischen
Spielregeln zu funktionieren hat dass es
keine Trennung zwischen Politik und ähm
und Gesellschaft geben kann und
ihre Normen und Werte orientieren sich
an dem äh was sie glauben dass im 7
jahrhundert zur Zeit der Mohammeds
gültig war also sie wollen quasi zurück
in in die Vergangenheit und
dann gibt es Gruppen die wollen das auf
friedlichem Wege durchsetzen und es gibt
welche die wollen das mit Gewalt
durchsetzen die letzten nennen wir
Jihadisten und es gibt nun in der Welt
eine ganze Reihe unterschiedlicher
dsihadistischer Gruppen die sich in
Krisensituationen Gründen in der Regel
und die Gruppe islamischer Staat also
is die hat sich ursprünglich gegründet
äh in Syrien und im Irak eigentlich gab
es mal die Idee dass der
zuständigbarkeitsbereich im arabischen
Raum ist aber 2014 hat sich dort
ein Führer dieses is äh dazu bekannt äh
dass er jetzt der neue Kalif ist äh und
ähm dass dieses Kalifat eine universelle
Gültigkeit beansprucht er hat also
gesagt das ist jetzt nicht ein Kalifat
in einem bestimmten Raum sondern das ist
das Kalifat das ist das Kalifat dem sich
alle Muslime anschließen sollen und
dieses Kalifat dieser is hatte von vorne
herein
Untergruppen sogenannte Provinzen in
denen eigene Akteure tätig waren und
quasi diese Botschaft weitergetragen
haben und auch mit Gewalt versucht haben
dafür zu sorgen
dass die Gebiete unterworfen sind und
sich dem Kalifen abubakar albagdadi war
das damals anschließen und da hat man
dann äh einen sogenannten Eid geschworen
und solche Gruppen finden wir in
unterschiedlichen ähm Regionen der Welt
viele sind äh in Afrika einige sind in
Asien aber auch in Zentralasien
Südostasien haben wir einige aber auch
in in Zentralasien und eine dieser
Gruppen ist eben die Abteilung für
korasan und korasan ähm das war eine
historische Provinz die umfasste
Afghanistan aber auch Tadschikistan das
was heute Tadschikistan usbekistan ist
unterschiedlich wie groß
dieses Gebiet war und darauf bezieht man
sich und dieses Gebiet war ursprünglich
auch eines das ganz früh missioniert
worden ist unter dem dritten Kalifen der
Muslime und
und diese Organisation ist ganz stark
international genau wie der gesamte is
seine Truppen
hat man aus allen Teilen der Welt
rekrutiert und das haben wir jetzt
sozusagen bei der Abteilung korassan
auch wenn gleich und das sehen wir ja
auch an den jenigen die verhaftet worden
sind es waren tajiken äh es sind schon
mal hat schon mal eine Verhaftung
stattgefunden da waren osbiiken dabei
ähm und ä also zentralasiatische Akteure
äh die jetzt sozusagen diese Mission
weitertragen wollen das heißt vom
arabischen Kernland ist der jihadismus
ein Stück weit in die Peripherie
gekommen aber mit dem Anspruch global
tätig zu sein und zwar vor allem in den
Peripherien
das sind sie ja jetzt auch mittlerweile
in Deutschland in Europa es gab
zusätzlich auch in Wien ähm Festnahmen
jetzt in den Weihnachtstagen und auch
Drohungen das heißt dieser Arm hat sich
jetzt in den letzten 5 se 7 8 Jahren
doch schon ganz schön weit nach Europa
gestreckt hat sich nach Europa gestreckt
aber es ist auch nicht so ganz neu also
Akteure die diesem is korasan angehören
kommen z.B aus der islamischen Bewegung
aus bekistan und die ist schon tätig
seit Anfang der 2000er Jahre auch in
Deutschland auch als Jihadisten da
wollten Sie auch schon Anschläge planen
ähm also es ist nicht eine ganz neue
Sache aber es hat vielleicht noch mal
eine neue Qualität jetzt m äh eine neue
Qualität also wenn ich jetzt lese ein
Ziel war möglicherweise nicht nur der
Kölner Dom sondern auch der Stefansdom
in Wien dann sind das ja
hochsymbolträchtige
Orte äh die man angreifen wollte wenn
sich das bewahrheitet und dann auch noch
in einer Zeit die
für uns hier in Europa besonders
symbolträchtig ist nämlich Weihnachten
und das die die Anschlags Drohung gehen
ja bis nach Silvester hinein das heißt
in eine Zeit die für uns sehr sehr
wichtig ist und wenn man es da schaffen
würde einen Anschlag durchzuführen dann
das ist die Hoffnung dieser Djihadisten
dann hätte das eine enorme Signalwirkung
und
solche Anschläge zielen ja immer darauf
dass sie eine Wirkung entfalten es geht
nicht um die Anschläge an sich sondern
es geht darum
dass man nach außen signalisieren möchte
wir sind stark
wir können unmögliches machen schließt
euch uns an mhm das sind jetzt die
jüngsten Ausrufezeichen die wir hier in
Europa mitbekommen haben es geht aber
schon seit 2014 das haben sie gerade
erklärt los
und daraus hat sich unter anderem dieser
sogenannte ispk gebildet und er hat auch
Vorort in der Region schon erste
Ausrufezeichen gesetzt Anschläge verübt
bei denen viele Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sind einen kurzen Überblick
wollen wir uns mal verschaffen den haben
Jonas Kapp und Sebastian Spiller
vorbereitet die Terrorgruppe islamischer
Staat Provinz korasan ist vor allem in
Afghanistan aktiv wurde wohl um 2015
gegründet und ihr sollen mehr als 1000
Menschen angehören der isbk gilt als
besonders radikal Bilder aus Afghanistan
vom August 2021 damals übernahmen die
radikal islamischen Taliban die macht
doch die sind dem isbk nicht radikal
genug bei dem Anschlag auf den kabula
Flughafen starben mehr als 170 Menschen
wenig später reklamierte der is-ableger
den Terrorangriff für sich damit wollte
der ispk zeigen dass die Taliban nicht
die Kontrolle haben mittlerweile ist es
ruhiger in Afghanistan geworden der
isaleger droht seitdem immer wieder mit
Anschlägen im Westen so wie jetzt in
Köln taschenkontroll an Heiligabend am
Dom wer den Gottesdienst will für den
ist das Pflicht und das gilt
weiterhin tja da haben wir auch schon
erste Zuschauerfragen reinbekommen einen
oder eine von Jannis Schröder der fragt
warum finden solche extremistischen
Ansichten eigentlich auch bei uns hier
in Deutschland lebenden Muslimen so
großen Anklang wir haben ja auch in den
letzten Jahren mitbekommen dass da
drazier verhaftet werden trotzdem gehen
die Pläne da mutmaßlich weiter das
Netzwerk ähm lebt weiter auch hier in
Deutschland wieso ist das so ja gut also
Attentäter oder potenzielle Attentäter
können einerseits Menschen sein die
zugereist sind also das kommt immer
wieder vor aber selbstverständlich ist
es auch so dass hier im eigenen Land
auch bei uns in Deutschland oder in
Österreich dass es dort
radikalisierungspotenzial gibt und das
liegt schlicht undter greifen daran äh
dass wir hier auch
ähm Parallelstrukturen haben in denen
Menschen relativ abgeschottet von der
Mehrheitsgesellschaft Leben und
ähm nach Normen äh sich verhalten die
uns doch äh also die dem Grundgesetz
ganz klar widersprechen muss man sagen
also im Bezug auf die Rechte der Frauen
im Bezug auf die Menschenrechte etc und
der Meinung sind dass für sie nur die
Botschaft Allahs gilt so wie das
bestimmte prädiger interpretieren ja
alles äh ist ja immer eine Frage der
Interpretation wie interpretiert man
heilige Texte welche Botschaften
religiösen Botschaften kommen an und wir
haben nun leider auch auch in
Deutschland immer noch Moscheen in denen
radikale Prediger
ja hetzerische Botschaften verkünden und
grundsätzlich mit dem Ziel ist des
Islamismus einverstanden sind und
dadurch wird natürlich
radikalisierungspotenzial immer wieder
bestärkt und bestätigt dazu kommen
natürlich die sozialen Netzwerke ja die
sozialen Netzwerke
in denen man allerlei Botschaften von
jedem Teil der Welt auch in Deutschland
empfangen kann wo man es kommunizieren
kann
und das ist gerade für die
isgruppen extrem wichtig weil sie ihre
Befehle oft von Akteuren außerhalb
Deutschlands erhalten und das geht dann
über soziale Medien und Sie können
denken Sie an das
an an den Anschlag von Breitscheidplatz
Anis Amri der der hat ein Video eine
Videobotschaft vorher verfasst und hat
die dann an den is geschickt und damit
hat der es dann diesen Anschlag
reklamiert also so funktioniert das
heutzutage dass man Befehle bekommt aus
einem anderen Teil der Welt und hier
gibt es dann Leute die danach handeln
weil sie glauben dass das Gott gefällig
ist weil sie glauben dass sie der Sache
des Islam damit nützen Frau Schröter
vielen Dank erstmal für den Moment wir
reden gleich noch weiter auch wie das
hier finanziert wird mit unter und wie
gut in Deutschland und in Europa dieser
islamistische Staat in der Provinz
kurassan organisiert ist danke schön
erstmal bis hierhin wir wollen vorher
noch einmal über die vergangenen Tage
und auch noch mal über die Zukunft rings
um den Kölner Dom reden und zwar mit dem
Polizeisprecher der Stadt Köln Wolfgang
Baldes er ist mir jetzt zugeschitet
einen schönen guten Abend zu Ihnen Herr
Baldes guten Abend aus Köln Herr Baldes
äh diese die diese Warnungen galten ja
Silvester sie sind schon vor Weihnachten
damit rausgegangen haben seither eine ja
hohe Bedrohungslage ihre Kolleginnen und
Kollegen waren rings um die
weihnachtswetage verstärkt vor Ort haben
Personenkontrollen durchgeführt
gleichzeitig gab es diese
Wohnungsdurchsuchungen und erste Haft
Namen sozusagen das klingt jetzt nicht
wirklich nach einem einigermaßen ruhigen
Weihnachtsfest für die Polizei Köln das
es da gab dieses
Jahr das war alles andere als ruhig wir
haben diesen Hinweis erhalten und am 23
haben wir die Öffentlichkeit über unsere
Erkenntnisse informiert ich muss
natürlich jetzt na ja etwas relativieren
wir haben sehr viel über is jetzt gehört
und man muss sagen ich kann das im
Grunde genommen jetzt nur auf die
aktuelle Kölner Situation noch mal
herunterbrechen wir haben von vorne rein
gesagt wir haben einen Hinweis wir
werden aus ermittlungstaktischen Gründen
natürlich nicht zu dem Hinweis zu der
Quelle und zu dem genauen Inhalt sagen
können aber wir haben von vorne rein
gesagt wenn wir eine Gefahr für die
Bevölkerung erkennen dann informieren
wir und dann geben wir natürlich auch
vor wie die Sicherheit hier rund um den
Kölner domum auszusehen hat man hat an
Weihnachten und
einen Tag davor schon gesehen was wir
alles gemacht haben man hat gesehen dass
wir ja Zelte draußen aufgestellt haben
es gab Einlasskontrollen
Taschenkontrollen wir haben von vorne
rein gesagt bringen sie gar keine
Taschen mit aber dann sind auch alle
Leute durchsucht worden das Heß wir
haben die Taschen geschaut wir haben in
die Kleidung geschaut ob jemand
gefährliche Gegenstände dabei hat um
eben ein maximale Sicherheit für die
Kölner Bevölkerung für alle die in den
Dom wollen zu ja gewährleisten mhm die
Ermittlungen laufen an unsere Zuschauer
interessiert das natürlich woher diese
Hinweise kam und auch ähm wie handfest
diese Hinweise waren da hatten wir
etliche Zuschauer fragen sie wollen da
heute Abend nicht zu Stellung nehmen
haben sie gerade erzählt es gab ähm dann
diese
Wohnungsdurchsuchung und diese
Haftstrafen erstmal gegen vier oder fünf
Männer einer von ihnen sitzt aktuell
noch in Gewahrsam muss man sagen wie
geht's jetzt mit diesem Mann weiter wird
er auch bald freigelassen oder er
nicht ja vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
zurück dass wir dazu nicht sagen wollen
das ist so nicht ganz richtig wir können
dazu gar nichts sagen weil man muss
natürlich sagen das eine ist der
Gefahrenhinweis dann gibt es natürlich
auch unsere Ermittlungen das sind
strafprozessuale Ermittlungen und wenn
wir die jetzt in die Öffentlichkeit
tragen würden dann würden wir natürlich
diese Ermittlung gefährden das verbietet
sich auf jeden Fall und diese Person die
wir in Wesel in Gewahrsam genommen haben
das ist eine Person die eine sehr ja
deutliche Nähe zu diesem Gefahrenhinweis
hat und deshalb haben wir gesagt wir
müssen diese Person in Gewahrsam nehmen
das nordrinwestfähische Polizeigesetz
gibt die Möglichkeit des Langzeit
gewwahrsams und weil dieser Hinweis sich
ursprünglich auf Silvester bezog deshalb
haben wir gesagt wir können da maximale
Sicherheit für uns und für die
Bevölkerung nur gewährleisten wenn diese
Person eben ein Silvester nicht draußen
ist und das Amtsgericht in Oberhausen
hat ein langzeitgewahrsam bis zum 7
Januar den wir angeordnet haben auch
soweit bestätigt mhm jetzt haben wir das
gerade schon auch in der Sendung noch
mal aufgeklärt dieser ispk der sitzt
seit etlichen Jahren schon in
Deutschland seit 2019 2021 gab's in der
Region
bei Ihnen auch noch mal schon erste
Festnahmen jetzt eben wieder Gewahrsam
Wie gut kennt ihr denn mittlerweile den
ispk das ist eine Frage die man äh dem
Staatsschutz stellen muss ich bin jetzt
der Pressesprecher der Polizei Köln
es ist immer wieder dass gerade der
islamistische Extremismus uns in Köln
fordert wir geben auch Lagebilder heraus
insofern haben wir viele Erkenntnisse
und man sagt und man kann natürlich
sagen dass wir in Köln eng mit anderen
Sicherheitsbehörden im Bund und Land
zusammenarbeiten diese Erkenntnisse
werden bewertet und wer Erkenntnisse hat
der bringt sie auch dort ein insofern
haben wir diesen Hinweis auch sehr ernst
genommen und haben gesagt hier müssen
wir sofort handeln mhm ich möchte mit
ihnen zum Abschluss her Baldes auf
Silvester blicken das was jetzt noch
ansteht die nächsten Tage da
interessiert z.B die Userin love sa auf
YouTube wird empfohlen generell Menschen
Ansammlungen Versammlungen zu vermeiden
rings um den
kölnerd nun ja das ist etwas was jeder
für sich selber entscheiden muss ich
kann nur aus polizeilicher Sicht sagen
dass wir die Erkenntnisse die wir jetzt
an Weihnachten gesammelt haben auch die
ganzen Ermittlungserkenntnisse zu denen
wir jetzt auch noch gar keine Stellung
nehmen in einen silvestereinsatz ja mit
einplanen insofern wird es ein
verändertes Einsatzkonzept auf jeden
Fall geben und dazu werden wir aber auch
noch vor Silvester Stellung nehmen auch
öffentlich insofern möchte ich dem auch
jetzt an dieser Stelle gar nicht
vorgreifen es wird aber sehr viel
Polizei rund um den DM zu sehen sein
genauso wie wir es auch in den letzten
Tagen schon ja gesehen haben n bleibt
die Bedrohungslage erstmal bestehen
diese erhöhte in dem kölnerd wir hatten
heute Nachmittag bei ZDF heute live die
Gelegenheit mit dem Sicherheitschef des
Kölner Doms Oliver Gassen kurz zu
sprechen wie er dann auf Silvester
schaut wie die Organisation die
Sicherheitsbestimmungen dort Vorort
jetzt ablaufen das hat er uns
geantwortet wir haben vor dem Dom in
enger und guter Kooperation mit der
Polizei Sicherheitskontrollen die
Personen werden durchsucht kurz GEP
Stücke lassen wir gar nicht zu also es
kommt nichts in den Dom was da nicht
reingehört und so können sich alle im
Dom sehr sehr sicher
fühen ja soweit Oliver Gassen der
Sicherheitschef des kölnerds mit ein
paar Eindrücken im kölnerd dann für die
weitere Planung wie schaut's denn
außenrum raus das ist ja dann ihr Revier
sind sie da auch so
entspannt n gut wir sind na entspannt
ist vielleicht das falsche Wort wir tun
alles für die Sicherheit der B ölkerung
deshalb werden wir da auch sehr massiv
zu sehen sein man sieht sicher viele
uniformierte Kräfte das wird die
jahreschluss Messe stattfinden da geht
es jetzt wieder um die Sicherheit im
domom aber das muss man sagen auch sehr
viele Polizeikräfte die im Einsatz sind
sehen nicht alles deshalb ist auch die
Bevölkerung aufgerufen jeder der dort
feiert sich eben einerseits an die
Regeln zu halten andererseits aber bei
verdächtigen Beobachtung sofort
Einsatzkräfte anzusprechen wir sind
natürlich auch mit zivilen Aufklärern da
insofern tun wir alles was in unserer
Macht steht um rund um den Dom und in
dem Dom für maximale Sicherheit zu
sorgen sagt der Sprecher der Kölner
Polizei Wolfgang Baldes ich bedanke mich
für das
Gespräch
gerne ja und damit zurück zu unserem
heutigen Studiogast Susanne Schröter ist
weiterhin bei mir etthnologin
Hochschullehrerin an der Goethe Uni
Frankfurt sie forscht seit Jahren zu dem
Themen Islamismus und jihadismus Frau
Schröter wenn mutmaßliche Terroristen zu
uns nach Deutschland kommen hier seid
etlich Jahren sitzen mit dem direkten
Willen Anschlagspläne zu schüren und
vielleicht auch junge Menschen die in
Deutschland leben anzuwerben erfolgreich
was bedeutet das für uns als
Gesellschaft und auch für die Politik na
das bedeutet dass wir mit so einem
latenten bedrohungs Gefühl leben müssen
bzw das ist das das ist das was ja nun
schmerzlich erstmal nicht zu ändern ist
aber langfristig müssen wir uns
natürlich Gedanken machen darüber wie
wir sich heit doch noch mal anders
herstellen also ähm meiner Meinung nach
kann es nicht sein dass wir tatsächlich
zulassen dass es hier abgeschottete
Milieus gibt
in denen Menschen nach völlig eigenen
Spielregeln leben die in also großteils
auch gegen die Gesellschaft gerichtet
sind dass sie tatsächlich der Meinung
sind im Land der Ungläubigen habe man
sich nicht nach
Gesetzen und Regeln zu halten sondern
man verharrt in so einer Feind
Bestimmung und ich glaube da das muss
man ernst nehmen wir sehen das in
anderen europäischen Ländern in den das
sehr viel weiter fortgeschritten ist in
Frankreich beispielsweise oder in
Schweden oder auch zum Teil in Belgien
und das sollte uns eigentlich eine
Mahnung sein dass wir rechtzeitig
versuchen Integration noch mal anders
auch einzufordern bzw dazu auch
ja Maßnahmen zu entwickeln ein ein
großer eine große Aufgabe fällt in
Schulen zu ich weiß das stöen jetzt alle
wiederusamen Gott nicht auch das noch
schon wieder aber gut alle jungen
Menschen gehen bei uns in die Schule und
ähm da ist im Prinzip die Möglichkeit
ähm dass auch alle Menschen etwas lernen
über Grundwerte die es bei uns in der
Gesellschaft gibt und
dass jeder natürlich seine Religion frei
leben kann aber Religion bedeutet eben
nicht dass ä sie an Stelle der Normen
Werte Regularien und Gesetze ähm
gestellt werden die bei uns gelten und
ähm das muss man in den Schulen
tatsächlich auch diskutieren D muss man
pädagogische Maßnahmen entwickeln und
ich weiß dass vor allem in
brennpunktgebieten
ähm dass da nicht alles zum Besten steht
dass es da durchaus äh Lehrer und
Sozialarbeiter gibt die sehr sehr gute
Ideen haben aber zum Teil sind sie noch
nicht durchgedrungen und da kann ich nur
alle Verantwortlichen auch ermuntern
dass eben Menschen die vom Fach sind und
die gute Ideen haben wie man präventiv
wirken kann auch in der Schule auch in
Jugendeinrichtungen dass sie die
Möglichkeit dazu auch bekommen mm unser
Zuschauer svenn odental odendah fragt
weiß man etwas wie sich diese
Terrorgruppen in Deutschland finanzieren
die Unterstützer na ja gut es kostet
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel jeder der
beim es tatsächlich ist in Afghanistan
kriegt kriegt ein Gehalt also ähm einer
jihadistischen Gruppe anzugehören ist
grundsätzlich lukrativ ob das jetzt für
diejenigen gilt die auch in Deutschland
sind das weiß ich nicht aber äh es gibt
Sponsoren aus dem arabischen Raum dort
wo auch viel Geld verhanden ist und da
gibt es natürlich etliche die auch
dihadistische organisationb
ähm in den Ländern in denen
jihadistische
Gruppierungen tatsächlich so erfolgreich
waren dass sie ganze Gebiete unter ihre
Kontrolle gebracht haben da haben sie
oft sehr einträglich gewirtschaftet
indem sie die Bevölkerung ausgeplündert
haben oder durch geiselnahen und
Schmuggel also die ganze Bandbreite an
an krimineller Wirtschaft mhm nun gibt's
Politiker die Verbindungen zum
Nahostkonflikt ziehen bayerns
Innenminister hermann hat das heute
gemacht in dem Zeitung Interview gesagt
je länger dieser Konflikt dauert desto
größer ist die Emotionalisierung und
damit die Gefahr dass jemand auf dumme
Gedanken kommt unterstreichen sie das
sehind sie auch Verbindungen das das
sehe ich absolut also a muss man sehen
wenn man sich die Geschichte
jihadistischer Bewegung anschaut und
auch von Jihadisten wo sind sie denn
überall mal
aufgefallen viele haben tatsächlich
einen Bezug zum zum Nahen Osten das
heißt sie sind absolut gegen Israel
eingestellt sie sind auf der Seite des
Islamischen Jihad oder anderer
Gruppierungen die da gewaltsam agieren
und
das
was jetzt im Nahen Osten tatsächlich
passiert bzw auch die ganze Propaganda
die wir im Moment haben
Hamas Propaganda ich bin ganz überrascht
dass wir auch in Deutschland Menschen
haben die verlieren kein Wort darüber
was die Hamas tatsächlich da für ein
Massaker angerichtet hat sondern man
sieht nur die andere Seite man sieht die
Opfer des israelischen
gegenschlags und das emotionalisiert
natürlich enorm und wenn man sich so ein
bisschen anschaut wie Menschen auf
diesen Konflikt reagieren dann muss man
sagen da da gibt es natürlich schon die
Gefahr dass das auch in Gewalt umschlägt
und dass daraus wieder ein
rekrutierungspotenzial für diese
jihadistischen Organisationen wie den is
cororassan erwächst also klar es kann
noch jemand einfach alleine losziehen
und kann Bess nehmen irgendjemand
erstechen das hatten wir ja auch alles
schon aber wir wissen auch dass solche
Organisationen wie der is rekrutiert ja
und sie haben in ihrer Geschichte
vielfach Mitglieder eingebüst weil sie
bei Militäroperationen eben auch
geschlagen worden sind aber ihnen ist es
immer wieder gelungen neue Mitglieder zu
rekrutieren und sie rekrutieren auch in
Europa und auch in Deutschland kommt da
so ein bisschen auch auf die
Verantwortung der jeweiligen Träger der
religiösen Gemeinschaften hier in
Deutschland an noch mehr Verantwortung
zu übernehmen noch mehr in den ähm
Versammlungen sozusagen da zu plädieren
dass die Tugenden die Werte und Normen
sozusagen bestehen bleiben das fragt z.B
Jürgen wörheide ja das würde ich mir
wünschen wenn äh die Muslime in
Deutschland ähm sehr viel aktiver würden
äh bei der Prävention des jihadismus und
äh oder alle Formen äh des Extremismus
im Namen des Islam und sich nicht
sozusagen aus der Verantwortung ziehen
dadurch dass sie sagen das hat alles
nichts mit dem Islam zu tun das ist zu
einfach ich finde
ähm Menschen die einer Religion
angehören und das ist in dem Fall der
Islam müssen sich eben auch mit
denjenigen beschäftigen die im Namen
ihrer Religion ähm großes Unheil
anrichten und da muss man auch eine
gewisse Verantwortung
verspüren und muss das eben auch in den
freitagspredigten oder in den
Gruppierungen in denen man Einfluss hat
muss man das deutlich machen dass
Religion in dieser Weise nicht den Segen
Gottes hat also das würde ich mir tun ja
auch viele Muslime aber ich würde mir
das doch noch mal sehr viel stärker
wünschen sagt Susanne Schröter von der
Uni Frankfurt Frau Schröter danke dass
Sie zu uns gekommen sind und ja für Sie
auch einen guten Rutsch dann die
nächsten Tage ja gerne danke Ja wir
danken euch auch heute wieder fürs
Interesse das war ZDF heute live für
heute wir sagen Danke fürs Einschalten
für eure Kommentare tschüss und bis
bald